[Music]
anyhow a guy who eats McDonald's
identified chicks with all those diet
cokes and it never exercises is in as
good of shape as you say season it's
called genetics I don't know it's some
people have you know just great genes
you know I told the president that if
you had a healthier dot over the last
twenty years he might live to be 200
years old his diet at all I just make
recommendations I'm not gonna comment on
that I mean you know I'm not comment on
that if that were my five-year-old I
might tell you they watch too much TV
but I'm not gonna you know the president
you know he can watch as much TV as he
wants media couldn't believe the
reaction today that was the president's
position Rear Admiral Ronny Jackson
answering the mainstream media is insane
and I mean literally insane I mean they
need psychological help psychiatric help
questions about the president's health
here with reaction now from the Trump
Organization president Trump's son Eric
Trump you know there's a part of this is
funny but it's not funny because they in
their little bubble echo chamber of
convinced themselves and you got asked
for a cognitive test which apparently
was one of the hardest ones that is any
a stick 34:30 it's actually this is
actually it's insane first of all I
think the Admiral did an amazing job I
do too second of all I mean does he
watch too much TV does he eat too much
ice cream are you kidding me by the way
if I look around that room half of the
people that were in there I remember
from the campaign yeah and I remember
them sleep-deprived drinking Red Bull
because they couldn't keep up with your
father as he was on his seventh speech
of the night they were in the back not
speaking in front of 30,000 people seven
times in a row in four different states
they're totally falling asleep they
can't keep up with him I mean my father
first of all I've never seen the man
with the cold second of all he has more
energy than any person I have ever met
in my entire life he will outwork
anybody he stays up I mean the guy is
incredible I mean I watched a charade
and I say give me a break guys
I mean but it's been non-stop I've
listed your dad's accomplishments for
the first year
anyone phenomenal promises made promises
kept just regulations alone energy
independence he got his tax bill done
end of the mandate and more finally open
somebody did it these are huge
accomplishments and now if I see the
economic economic boom that is unfolding
before our eyes and they're upset that a
president is healthy it's excellent
health you know with that result watch
as much TV as you want
that's great the Dow is about to break
26,000 yeah right you have the lowest
actually did today unemployment that
you've ever had before you have the
lowest african-american unemployment
that you have you the highest consumer
confidence you've ever had
Isis is quite frankly a thing of the
past you had 44,000 terrorists are down
to less than a thousand and they're
killing those guys off rapidly you know
well you know what they don't like
it's insane they don't like that he's
not them yeah they don't like that he
has different views they don't like that
he's more irreverent and more
politically incorrect
they can't handle that they were wrong
they don't like that I don't like that
they were wrong they got it wrong they
all got it wrong they were supposed to
be the smart people who got to call this
every time they were the brilliant
journalists they all got it wrong he
quite frankly embarrassed them and
they're doubling down again and he's
gonna prove them wrong again and again
because you know what every day and I
told you this metaphor a thousand times
but it happens to me every single day I
walk down the street and people come up
to me they hug me tell your father we
say thank you you know what I just
opened up my 401k I haven't looked at it
in a year it's up by 35 percent I mean I
didn't think retirement was possible I
hate Wall Street I wish I was up 35% and
now it is I mean do you know that the
stories I hear every single day shun him
you know what people tell Mabel
difference in this country please don't
stop fighting because they know that
this is like an oasis here this is we're
not them and I never by the way I've
never been a White House Correspondents
Dinner because I hate them and they hate
me so it works out well here's what I
want to ask you imagine this scenario
where it's proven in the head of your
party the Republican Party said that
Donald Trump rigged a primary election
rigged it what they thought of Brazil's
words not mine then your dad paid for
Russian propaganda to with salacious
lies and and misinformation against
Hillary Clinton to influence the general
election then we find out that the FBI
director and some of his minions put the
fix in and exonerated your father before
an investigation and then we find out
that that phony Russian paid for dossier
that was used wanted that they wanted to
use to manipulate the American people
before an election to steal the general
where they stole the primary that that
was used to get a warrant on Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton's team an
opposition candidate and then and then a
president elect Hillary thank God we
don't have to say that
what would the media be doing tonight
well I mean how about just going back to
the very beginning where Donna Brazile
is giving the debate questions to
Hillary before the debate Amit can you
imagine if that happened happened in my
father I mean let alone all this other
stuff meaning he would have been
disqualified at that moment there would
be nothing left at that moment let alone
the fake dossiers and the phony
investigations and the nonsense Russia I
mean here's here's just a reality of
what happened you had a better candidate
who was far more competent who worked
much harder despite having 1/7 the
amount of money who blew the other party
out of the water right and they needed
they needed an excuse they needed a way
to justify their loss and if you look at
the Democratic Party right now they have
no message they have no leadership they
have no nothing Talent hey Trump and and
no vision to help the Forgotten men and
women of this country you know what I
think the best thing that dad does he
goes he's given one of his speeches or
town halls or whatever you do see those
people in the back fake news and you
know what everyone starts screaming they
turn and they tell them they're
screaming at people in the media you
suck and they still don't care
they still don't understand it's amazing
I mean think about having an approval
rating that's equivalent to the media's
approval rating which is single digits
right now or I didn't you look at any
poll I mean wouldn't you want to change
course and maybe this is a business guy
in me if something's not working look at
CNN's ratings right good point they have
zero ratings right if something's not
working what do you want to change
course as opposed to doubling down and
doubling down
and 95 times they said chole on the fake
news all Network sorry I can't help I
can't help it they told me I can't say
it on the air and it pissing me all the
way not one time did they mention the
Dow hitting 26,000 no not one time did
they talk about Isis let me back to this
country now one time did they talk about
Oasis I mean everything that's actually
important to this nation and you know
the one thing I learned through this
whole process I mean if there's one
thing that I'll take away is that the
media does not understand at least the
vast majority of the media does not
understand the voice of this country
it's controlled out in New York it's
controlled out of LA it's controlled by
not the country though six six people
right at the very very top who's you
know at any point that they care about
the men and women in poverty out of work
and on food stamps at any point do they
care about national security at any
point did they examine it was dumb a
Bill Clinton and Obama to try and bribe
murdering dictators to like us because
unless he was your father ilene dollars
away I'm in a cargo plane with currency
from a million countries complaining
about eighteen billion dollars for a
wall but they're willing to give Iran
150 billion dollars I mean just doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't make sense I know
you guys are tough I actually say this
all the time you can take it your
brother can take it your sister can take
it Jared can take it then they pick on
the first lady and your 11 year old
brother and they don't stop they don't
even see that as being wrong there there
are no boundaries honestly there are
there are no boundaries it actually it's
it's almost the worst of humanity
sometimes there are no boundaries the
way you don't go after a twelve-year-old
child you just don't I mean 12 now
somewhere right there I'll focus on my
four month old who's growing fast I wish
we could show the picture of your little
boy that you sent me it was great they
went after him as well right I mean
that's before he's born before his more
Chelsea Handler what would a jab she
goes you know I hope you have a
miscarriage I mean that's Eve it this is
the level of evilness that you have out
there it's it's it's sick right I got it
wrong good to see you thanks for
stopping by our audience like to hear
from you